I'm Dan Peralta here are the top 10 most
anticipated movies of 2016 according to
you number 10 the Jungle Book director
Jon Favreau has reimagined the jungle
book as a live action adventure based on
the first trailer this might have the
tools visuals number 9 Zoolander 2 our
favorite use of the runway earth back
and Mike anchorman Oh everything number
8 x-men apocalypse
it's an x-men movie set in the 80s aside
from those awesome eighties Heritage's
and spandex we're also getting the first
live-action appearance of apocalypse
mutant with godlike powers there's
plenty of returning characters like
Jennifer Lawrence's mystique but we're
also seeing the younger versions of
classic x-men like Cyclops and storm
number 7 Independence Day resurgence
taking place 20 years after the original
the aliens are back to invade Earth once
again no Will Smith this time around but
we are getting Thor's little brother
Liam Hemsworth and hopefully we'll get
to hear this in an Aussie accent
welcome to earth number 6 Star Trek
beyond this film will celebrate the 50th
anniversary of Star Trek and introduce
an original villain
played by Indra Spellman this time
around Justin Lin will be directing this
JJ Abrams was busy shooting Star Wars
The Force awakens
number 5 Captain America Civil War so
Iron Man Captain America disagree or
something happens to all friends but
this time it results in a battle between
Captain start that forces all our
favorite superheroes to take sides
I'm on Team cap number 4 Jason Bourne
not much is known about the new Bourne
movie except that Matt Damon is ripped
director Paul Greengrass has been pretty
mom on plot details but Damon has said
it takes place in a coastal snowed-in
world number 3
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice it's
the year of superheroes versus
superheroes and this match is one of the
most anticipated of all time not only
will it bring Ben Affleck's Batman to
the DC Cinematic Universe
he'll also introduce Lex Luthor Wonder
Woman and Aquaman number 2 finding dory
this sequel follows one of the most
popular and forgetful Pixar characters
of all time
Ellen DeGeneres is back his dory who's
on a mission to find her family if she
can only remember anything about that
I remembered something that's not
possible is it and now your most
anticipated film of 2016
broke one a Star Wars story rogue one
tells the story of the rebels who fought
to capture the Empire's Death Star plans
this should serve as a fun standalone
film but it could also set up future
Star Wars movies rumor has it broke one
actor dawn again will also appear in
Star Wars Episode eight and another
rumor has it that I see
favors like 70 times 16 times fun myself
what else you looking forward to 2016
let us know in the comments section
below and don't forget to subscribe I'm
being off thank you for watching